give the audience who doesn't know your
background I was born in Iran in 1972
which makes me 50 which is insane
uh thank you I appreciate that uh my
family was you know like an upper middle
class family landowning uh family big
large uh tribal family my father uh was
a kind of a troublemaker
um communist uh today
exactly yeah yep yep but like college
today the way that all college kids are
sort of communist do you know you know
my family too yeah so my mother said so
today today if you want to share with
the audience what today is so today was
the primary Communist party in Iran in
the 1970s and it actually had a massive
role in the success of the 1979
Revolution that got rid of the Shaw and
that eventually about a little more a
little less than a year later uh
replaced the Shah with Khomeini whose
First Act was to get rid of all the
Communists
so it's just kind of crazy they thought
they were going to make it better for
two days but it got worse for them they
thought they could control the religious
Fanatics and if that if there's not a
lesson there then you're not paying
attention right it's I think the
Communist party they were the
intellectuals of the movement they gave
the movement uh teeth and they helped uh
I think you know less politically minded
people understand exactly what was at
stake in this revolution but in the end
it's the religious uh leaders who have
the ability to bring people out onto the
streets right ideas don't go anywhere if
there aren't thousands of people willing
to risk their bodies in order to
implement those ideas and so it was this
weird marriage
of convenience to begin with right these
like secularist mainly atheists uh
intellectuals and communists
and the religious Pious masses they
married together to get rid of the Shah
but then as soon as the Shah was gone
the cracks in that relationship very
quickly formed and and I remember very
clearly my father uh one morning very at
least for my seven-year-old perspective
very suddenly saying it's time to go we
got we got to go right one year this was
79 so oh you left in 79. so it left
after the Shah uh left left after
Khomeini arrived where did he live where
did you live where in Iran did you live
in Tehran what part of Tehran oh we were
in the north okay yeah yeah nice area
yeah we're the nicer area we had we had
things gone what city would you say if
you didn't gone the area like what area
do you remember the area or no I don't
remember the exact there was an area
like if you lived in the north you're
like uh to say what would be the you
know
uh it's like saying you lived in Beverly
Hills type of area maybe not Beverly
Hills but it's like to say you live in a
good area yeah well I will say that like
those people the the very rich people
they got the message way before anybody
else
they all got out with their Swiss bank
accounts uh intact and have you been
back to Iran since you left in 79 just
once I went back in 2005 before I I was
anyone and when I could just kind of you
know sneak under the the radar yeah
um it was this was right after Ahmad uh
became president was like yeah it was a
crazy time and I went back for about
eight nine weeks
um on a research trip but also to see my
family to see my you know the home and
just to kind of see what the place was
like
um that's probably the last time I'll
get to see Ron what would happen if you
went back now and what do you think
would happen if someone like Pat would
go back now because that's a lifelong
dream of his I just don't know the
reality of it I think
I think that if I went back now uh I
would probably be never heard from again
I'd probably disappear at the airport I
think if Pat went back now he would be
welcomed with open arms and then someone
would knock on his door a few days later
and say you sent a text uh and that text
makes you a spy come with us
does there need to be any justification
for them you know taking you away or is
it just that the theocrats are just
gonna come get you and that's just how
it works see here's here's the the The
Awful Truth about Iran is that there are
a lot of ways that we could label it
that it's a Theocratic regime or that
it's a fascist regime or that it's like
a military regime
but the truth of the matter is that like
most autocratic States
it's impossible to really know who's in
charge of what right the the person in
charge of your life is the guy on the
other side of the desk
you know if he's a bureaucrat yeah if
he's had a nice lunch
and uh and you know had a nice
conversation with his wife then maybe
you're okay if he had a fight with his
wife then you're screwed and and it's
not like you can point to the law to say
but that's not how it works right
um in countries like Iran the law is
whatever the person in front of you says
the law is and that makes these kinds of
situations very difficult so when an
American citizen of Iranian Heritage
which happens quite often uh gets
arrested and accused of these sort of
very vaguely worded crimes
um it's very hard for the the American
government to kind of do anything
legally to support them because the law
is such an absolute mess over there is
there is there a law in Iran an
established constitutional law that
provides for uh a fair judicial process
for anyone committed who who is uh
allegedly committed a crime yeah
absolutely does anyone pay any attention
to that no I mean you can appeal to it
but people just sort of laugh at you
that's the problem with not just Iran
but all of these sort of autocratic
States police go back to the to the
upbringing so I'm following I'm tracking
all of it that today it's kind of a
rebel like the younger ones like you
know two days in a movie theater you
would stand up to kind of give
recognition to the Shaw and two days
wouldn't stand up like they would do
they were Rebels they were like stuff
like that yeah and then go ahead
continue we're listening so seven years
old you guys that you're the your dad
says we got to get out of here 79 right
before Khomeini right after Shaw you
guys leave you come to the states yeah
and and I think for my dad too people
don't people forget that when how many
how many Jesus when Khomeini returned
just so you know to Americans it's the
same thing but to us yes no yeah
when he corrected himself Americans are
like what is he doing please
but there's a big difference yes
would you for the for us uh Gringo
Americans pronounce the different names
was the founder of the Islamic Republic
and and the guy who invented the very
idea of the Supreme leader Khamenei is
the current Supreme so say the two names
two totally separate words it is exactly
it doesn't sound anything alike anyway
the point is is that you know when he
came back I think people people don't
remember this when he when he uh
returned from Exile in in Iran there's
millions of people came out you know to
sort of Welcome him as the savior of the
of the new Iran he very publicly
announced that he wanted nothing to do
with politics that he had no interest in
government that you know he was happy
that the Shah was gone but he just
wanted to be left alone he wanted to go
back to his home and to his family into
his mosque into his studies and my dad
who never trusted anything anyone
wearing a turban had to say on any
subject just thought
[ __ ] like that's I don't believe
that for a minute and so just in case
let's grab some things and go and if it
if it does turn out okay we'll come back
you know let's just leave for a little
bit so that's what it was it was very it
was really an emergency thing you know
wake up in the morning grab some things
put it in a suitcase we're gonna just
leave for a little while
and that was obviously what you guys go
to straight here or did you go like to
Spain and then you came here was it like
a inner uh we there was a brief stop in
London for a lot of Iranians checking
out London was like stop number one uh
but that's funny for us our destination
in the United States was Oklahoma
was Enid Oklahoma and I to this day I
can't tell you exactly why my my my
theory is that when my dad was in
college he did like a semester abroad at
a at a university in Oklahoma I think in
Edmonton I believe I don't remember
Eastern Oklahoma I'm sorry Oklahomans
that I I'm unaware of your geology just
throw them on the bus
um and I think he just thought well
that's America like that's Oklahoma is
America and Bread Basket so if we go to
America then we're going to land in
Oklahoma by the way he's right in a lot
of ways but it only took us about a year
to realize oh there's so much more about
America and so like so many Iranians we
headed west and ended up in California
but in Northern California not in
Southern California different Iranian
diaspora where uh in the Bay Area okay
yeah there's a big Community there well
the bear it's like a different community
so the first Iranians who led the
wealthy ones who like took their money
with them all settled in Los Angeles and
so there's a reason we call La
terangelis you know
um and but then the sort of
intellectuals the second wave the
post-revolution people who got out they
all settled in the Bay Area so it's a
vastly different community in California
the Northern California Iranians and the
Southern California regions so but for
today to escape to leave an escape
that that doesn't make sense though
because I'm assuming your dad was not a
fan of the shaw right no he was not a
family so so how
that is a very strange kudos to your dad
by the way for for making that decision
but for knowledge yeah because that
doesn't make sense though that doesn't
make because the level of hate today's
had for the Shah was so massive yeah
that they all wanted anything but the
Shah because obviously you know the
whole look how rich she is look at the
2500 Year celebration he put together
anything is better than the show this is
the thought well I'm surprised that he
left
and I think for my dad the the two-day
politics was married to a real
anti-religious hardcore atheist
materialism view yeah like I always joke
that my dad was the kind of atheist who
always had a pocket full of prophet
Muhammad jokes that he would pull out at
inappropriate times you know what I mean
like he was a very kind of viral
virulently anti-religious
person how old were you the first time
you read Communist Manifesto
really I'm actually curious I mean
honestly it's probably not until I was
like 13 14. okay so you read it here you
didn't read it in Iran no yeah that was
like the Bible you know for two-day
party you know you have to read that to
get an understanding about bourgeoisie
and you know uh all the other guys
anyways okay so your your religious
ideology like how religious beliefs
you've you've kind of gone through a
little bit of if you don't mind sharing
that with the audience well so you know
we grew up uh culturally Muslim the way
that so many people are culturally
religious around the world it was just
kind of part of who we were it was part
of our identity
um and you know we would go we would go
through the the rituals and the holidays
and all that stuff but when we came to
the US I think my father thought aha
well there now we don't even have to
pretend anymore like we don't have to
pay lip service to any of that you know
we'll put the Quran away and and roll up
the prayer rugs and that's the end of
that my mother you know was raised a
little bit differently she was raised
primarily by my um by her grandmother
her parents were
famous actors you know in Iran which in
Iran is kind of another way of saying
prostitute
um and so she basically raised by by
just so you know he's right she was
basically raised by her very strict
grandmother and so you know my mother
would would pray every once in a while
and and
um we would do some of the holidays but
but the more we stayed in Iran the more
I grew up I'm sorry in the US the more I
grew up in the U.S
um the more and more we systematically
stripped our lives and our family of any
kind of religiosity but you have to
understand you know I was seven when my
country was handed over to religious
Fanatics and I remember it I was there
on the streets I watched it happen and
it I think instilled in me
at a very young age
with religion and the power that
religion has to transform a society for
good and for bad and and the way that
religion can be used as a way to uh to
make change but to also identify
yourself to create groups and in groups
out groups I got really fascinated by
Legends and mythologies
um I was just a weird boy like that was
a weird boy I was interested in religion
but in a family in which there was no
place to really Express that in any
meaningful way so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]